o a tudo isto que falou dar que sejam
muito bem vindos e é mais um dia de hoje
11 é hoje nesta segunda-feira o trago do
chef nation
já outro que não esteve aqui na itália
eu sair eu saio mas hoje não sei porque
tem opção gravar ou 2019 tamanho de um
gato eo que jogar aqui dentro eu não
saiu devido a um problema nos bom vamos
lá eu começar pessoal vamos ligar o
nosso regredir no filme sugeriu em taxar
o andar da icla opel que o facebook o
andré consegue queen no call of duty bts
gostei de ver gráfico ser caso e ofender
ou menos bom em português é não só
personagem é um design também não o seu
personagem é famoso pelo futebol não é
famoso por ser um nome quando dentro do
caixão e mata uma pessoa e seu
personagem usa roupas masculinas
eu acho que uns falam restritivo só usam
cueca mesmo assim seu personagem gosta
do computador graus imagem já matou
alguém não sei alegou que é nome com
certeza tinha muito ao grêmio e vou
dizer que não saiu a cair o seu
personagem já morreu andré deca adaptar
e ter culpa é do governo em português ou
seja um em cada pessoa já morreu
angela já museus e seu personagem vive
da música não seu personagem europeu não
sair
imagem é real sam witwicky personagem
está ligado ao cinema ou respondeu um
pouco de ficção não é portanto é é não
não se está já está morto há mais de mil
anos não o seu personagem é um cidadão
dos estados unidos eu acho que é essa
personagem já foi possível que um país
não seu personagem é negro não o seu
personagem já fingiu ser outra pessoa
sem o andré e ele finge ser um lutador
um companheiro é seu personagem faz
tutoriais maquiagem ou pintar a cara eu
tento aos lábios olhos méxico não ensina
não o seu estágio é dono de uma empresa
não saiu como fazer perguntas que não
sabe se o personagem está morto há mais
de 20 anos não aqui nem 37 destes é
quando tem que tá morto no sentido
figurado da palavra
cada composição interna do hospital a
gente faz parte de uma série de tv pode
ser pop
sim o seu estágio é grande muito grande
é gostoso nosso técnico está já foi
membro do wwf é a cnae ter peixe parar
de desenhar essas coisas para mim o jogo
vinha o seu personagem usa um chapéu
preto
quem mais dandão o danilo é usar um
chapéu preto batista o batistão bom não
só um detalhe que recusa eu vai viajar
assim não pode ser o disco imagem estava
morto e eu fui associar um morto uma
pessoa viva eu não acho que essa taxa é
a fruta chanfros eu vou procurar quem é
fruto só pessoal esta é frouxa época já
no carlitos quer que eu vá à procura da
frondosa e o príncipe al qaeda funcionam
essas rodas e postagem está relacionada
ao futebol não é português não sabe mais
quem é real não se o personagem é um
super-herói senac é um super chorar não
não é o seu personagem é um homem adulto
não porque é uma mulher né o seu
personagem é disney sim pronto eu já
tinha o seu personagem é loiro sim sim
aquino o seu estágio faz parte trouxe é
preciso um acerto direto que não vale a
pena perguntar mais tempo não o seu
personagem estreou em timbuí tchan e não
todas não eu acho que é a rainha é alça
não dá na gestão era bom era fácil era
muito fácil esta no entanto esta não
contou nem assim acertar sakineh e
ganhei a cara de bobo flist pupo próxima
personagem que surgiu esta personagem
foi o nó da amazon é desfrutado outro
momento tenta o batman batman quem será
o pato não saibam
an o seu personagem é famoso assim o seu
personagem está com o sinal do futebol
no seu personagem usa roupas filme médio
enem sim porque lá na lei com uma cueca
bem apertada uma sonda nenhuma eu vou
dizer que não pra mim mas pra mim ela é
feminina com essa personagem vive em
portugal não só personagem luta sim o
seu estágio é um super herói se
sobressaem está ligado à cor vermelha
não é os madrilenos e postagens atua em
pretty little liars alguns quilômetros
do primeiro gol o nível em 2 20 do e
1010 ou eu não sei q se muito em
campo o seu personagem usa uma máscara
sim eu até falo assim encostar uol o seu
personagem usa uma capa sem o seu
personagem possui um carro sim é o bate
carro roubado mobio o seu personagem é
paulista maurício que paulista a é um
absurdo de são paulo o culto bem o seu
conjunto é eu acho que batman disse
comics encontrou o batman
a sugestão dela e cravo é a seguinte faz
do resende e vou eu não consegue
adivinhar
eu já tentei ou seja é que nós já temos
a confirmação que estamos à procura do
resende ivo não vai por ser o que eu
duvido nem porque tem mais vil ceilândia
tem muita viu eu sou fã eu faço tanta de
uma estante digo que o pessoal lá da
china deve ver o filme com a cni atribui
chato mas vamos à procura de uma coisa
uma coisa que nem sequer uma faca um
personagem ao cair a moeda é uma coisa
que está aqui na minha mão agora que ó ó
moeda 11 e pra quem não sabe que por
razões têm feito boi vídeos da moeda ou
comprar moedas o euro como moeda
eu acho que ele inventou a 1 é colocar
eu gostava da minha não convinha
também por isso a moeda perto do vidro
com o akinator consiga encontrar a moeda
porque nem sequer uma faquinha imagem
por isso vamos tentar enganar o aqui
dentro com isto se eu aceitar por
seu personagem mora no seu país não o
seu personagem luta não é baixo não
lutam por enquanto por enquanto o seu
personagem é do gênero feminino não não
é o que define não exclui o seu
personagem está relacionada ao futebol
não possui margem é real sim o
personagem gosta do computador não
subscrevem já no rio a moeda não é um
ser vivo portanto amor
não morreu porque uma pessoa pra morreu
há alguma coisa pra morrer tem que tá
viva antes né
só nunca teve veto não morreu porque né
não não é seu personagem é um ator ano o
seu personagem vivo da música não do seu
personagem está ligado esportes não o
seu personagem já casou não olha o
atleta já tudo confuso o seu personagem
é um animal não viu tem mais de 30 anos
não se o personagem tem mais de dez anos
né o seu personagem é um ser humano
também não o seu personagem tem dois
olhos não se o personagem pode ser
encontrado sim nós somos do shopping nós
vamos conseguir encontrar a noiva já à
venda portanto sim seu personagem é
nojento sim seu personagem é marrom
marrom é castanho cá e não o seu estádio
gosto de transar fazer o sexo não é só
isso já é feito em papel também não se
imagem de mau cheiro e nunca teve uma
moeda portanto não sei se eu vou dizer
consegue o seu personagem está ligado é
hospitais não o seu personagem na tua
própria família o botafogo como ela
assina o seu personagem é macho também
não quer ou não pode ser o seu
personagem é macho não olha é tomar
moeda andré não dá não dá só acirra
deixa eu ver quantas pessoas já
procuraram este ano 11 mil 11 mil e
trezentas vezes procuraram amoeba já
sabem comentei nos comentários
personagens ainda mais difíceis do que
estas mil eu acabei de procurar um
objeto eo encontrou eu faço outro vídeo
aqui na inter já sabem o quanto eu gosto
aqui favorito fique bem até a próxima